balade poétique une voie pour un texte
me permet de partager avec tous les
publics
cette grande oeuvre de notre patrimoine
et du patrimoine mondial de la
littérature et c'est pour réconcilier le
public avec cahier d'un retour au pays
natal qui souvent effraie les gens par
sa difficulté
est-ce que ça a été facile de le
découper le texte ça a été facile oui et
non facile pourquoi parce que ça fait 20
ans que je travaille ce texte
donc je le connais bien maintenant mais
c'est toujours très difficile parce que
c'est une grande oeuvre et les grandes
oeuvres sont difficiles à torturer à
découper il faut avoir une très bonne
connaissance du rythme de l'écriture
césairienne des images de l'univers des
mots d'aimé césaire pour réussir à faire
un montage de textes cohérent c'est à
dire que le défi pour un artiste c'est
de donner l'illusion au public que les
textes qui lui propose ont été cousus
ensemble l'un à la suite de l'autre
alors qu'en fait je découpe je prends
des partis je joue à peu près 80% du
cahier pourquoi pas plus parce que je
souhaite jamais que mes spectacles
dépasse une heure parce que j'estime
qu'au delà d'une heure
la concentration du public devient
se délient un peu donc je le maintiens
en transe en éveil poétique pendant une
heure et aimé césaire c'est vrai est un
auteur qui a produit des textes
difficiles mais en aucun cas
inaccessible donc je transmets de
différentes manières c'est à dire qu'en
tant qu'enseignante je transmets à mes
élèves pendant mes cours
mais en tant qu'artiste et conférencière
je crée des formats pour que tout le
monde puisse s'y retrouver